on va parler d'éducation à présent avec
une nouvelle chronique présentée par
notre journaliste Régine ralech et du
Talk et pour ce premier numéro on va
parler de la forest internationale
School et donc nous sommes justement
avec la fondatrice de cette école Julie
Muller Régine est-ce que vous pouvez
nous présenter en quelques mots
qu'est-ce que cette école forest
internationale School et oui Mathilde
alors cette école elle a été créée en
2004 et elle est basée à Mareil Marly
près de Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est une
école privée hors contraste c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'a pas signé d'accord avec
l'État cette école est propose également
un programme bilingue donc à 70% en
anglais et quelques autres cours en
français et pourquoi bilingue parce que
c'est une école qui s'adresse
majoritairement à des enfants de parents
expatriés alors ce qui fait également la
particularité de cette école c'est son
apprentissage par le mouvement et son
apprentissage en extérieur alors je vous
rassure tous les cours ne sont pas à
l'extérieur il y a aussi des cours en
classe à l'intérieur mais sur place
quand moi je m'y suis rendue il y avait
par exemple ce professeur de
mathématiques qui enseignait ses élèves
comment se servir des mathématiques pour
par exemple construire des matériaux et
donc les élèves vont par exemple déjà
construit des carillons avant avec des
bambous ou même des prototypes
d'aspirateur pour savoir à peu près
comment ça fonctionne et je dirais
également que la force de cette école
c'est aussi la différenciation
pédagogique mais alors c'est quoi la
différenciation pédagogique alors la
différenciation pédagogique excusez moi
alors c'est dans une classe il y a des
élèves avec des capacités et des modes
d'apprentissage différents et donc
l'enseignant lui justement va prendre en
compte toutes ces particularités les
forces et les faiblesses de ces élèves
et justement c'est l'école qui va
s'adapter à l'élève et non l'inverse
alors évidemment c'est une chose qui est
possible à la forest International
School pourquoi parce que les classes
sont peu nombreuses elles elles sont
composées entre 8 et 12 élèves et vous
vous êtes rendus la semaine dernière
justement vous avez interviewé les
parents et les professeurs on regarde
tout de suite votre reportage
[Musique]
un des choses que j'aime le plus chez
Forest National je pense que c'est que
la pensée critique est mise au centre de
tout ce que j'aime c'est on va vous
encourager à penser qu'est-ce que je
peux faire avec ce savoir-faire
qu'est-ce que je peux construire avec ce
savoir-faire
[Musique]
alors Julie Muller on le voit dans cette
vidéo on entend de l'anglais de
l'espagnol combien de nationalités
avez-vous au sein de votre école
à l'école Brest il y a beaucoup de monde
du enfin les gens viennent du monde
entier et et on accueille des familles
avec des enfants qui ne parlent pas
nécessairement ni en gagnant français et
voilà du fait des petites effectifs on
va pouvoir les intégrer rapidement ils
apprennent très très vite par les
langues et le français justement le
programme est bilingue majoritairement
en anglais j'imagine j'imagine que pour
certains l'anglais ça peut quand même
poser quelques problèmes c'est pas trop
compliqué
pour certains élèves
dont pas plus que d'apprendre le
français enfin on accueille des enfants
du monde entier donc pour eux c'est une
langue étrangère comme une autre
et alors justement je lui dis Muller des
écoles de ce type on en trouve pas
énormément en France si on en compte
actuellement une trentaine est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer un peu la
genèse de cette école et pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez décidé d'ouvrir une école
de ce type donc Forrest International
School on a créé à 19 ans avec ma mère
et l'idée c'était de créer une école où
les enfants et du plaisir à venir avec
qu'ils arrivent le matin avec un grand
sourire et
on a commencé tout petit on avait une
classe et petit à petit on a on a créé
des nouveaux espaces et des nouvelles
classes les nouveaux bâtiments
l'idée c'est de créer une école avec ou
en incorpore l'extérieur avec les
classes donc on va apprendre on va
enseigner aux enfants les
les matières académiques le matin par
exemple et quelques après-midi par
semaine on va faire des activités comme
ce que vous avez montré là à l'extérieur
en forêt ou alors dans le dans
l'enceinte de l'école et justement vous
le disiez donc il y a une place
importante de la nature pourquoi est-ce
que vous jugez que c'est important
aujourd'hui pour les enfants de passer
du temps à l'extérieur c'est essentiel
vous avez parlé de la différenciation
travailler à l'extérieur c'est
travailler sur des projets concrets et
en travaillant comme ça à l'extérieur un
peu différencier c'est à dire qu'on peut
s'adresser aux différents types
d'apprentissage des enfants les
différents intelligences et on peut
faire du multi niveau
aujourd'hui bien sûr il y a une réalité
en termes d'environnement et le fait de
les sortir tous les jours aller en forêt
ça permet d'observer les petits détails
aller voir les insectes voir comment la
faune et la flore évolue donc là
actuellement en forêt il y a des il y a
plein de plantes et des bourgeons des
bourgeons qui sortent et donc ce qu'on
veut faire c'est vraiment permettre à
l'enfant d'être
en symbiose avec son environnement et de
prendre le temps d'observer parce qu'on
y a énormément d'apprentissage
potentiels à l'extérieur du coup cette
pédagogie elle se casse un petit peu
avec la pédagogie traditionnelle qu'on
connaît en tout cas dans les écoles
publiques
est-ce que justement comme vous êtes une
école hors contrat est-ce que vous avez
tout de même des obligations envers
l'éducation nationale comment est-ce que
ça ça marche tout à fait alors on est
obligé de passer par eux pour
l'ouverture de l'école c'est une demande
d'affaires auprès du rectorat ensuite on
se fait inspecter quasiment chaque année
et il faut montrer les diplômes de tous
les professeurs et il faut vraiment
soutenir déjà la candidature quand on
l'ouvre l'école mais par la suite il
faut vraiment
montrer carte blanche patte blanche
c'est à dire il faut être en règle
vis-à-vis de l'accessibilité
les pompiers passent etc donc il faut
vraiment complètement en règle tout
comme les établissements publics mais
vous avez quand même une bonne marge de
liberté
et vous avez le même programme aussi
enfin où c'est complètement différent en
termes de de maths d'histoire géographie
nous suivons internationale school on
suit le curriculum anglais donc il y a
des similitudes avec avec ce qui se fait
en France par contre il faut montrer des
parallèles et montrer que par exemple
les multiplications dans les anciennes
puissent moi-même au même âge après en
Europe les choses les programmes sont
quasiment les mêmes et sont assez
uniformes mais non il faut il faut
vraiment jouer le jeu alors même si on
fait pas partie de du réseau
il faut
et voilà il faut il faut montrer qu'on
est
quand on fait des apprentissages et qui
a des similitudes avec le système
français et justement en parlant de
système français de système anglais en
allant sur place j'ai interviewé
justement une maman donc Annabelle
Roberts elle est canadienne et elle vit
en France depuis 2008 et elle m'a dit
avoir été assez surprise du système en
France pour elle en France les filières
scientifiques et les métiers
d'ingénierie sont souvent mis en avant
et justement la question que que je me
pose c'est est-ce que vous c'est quelque
chose que vous prenez en compte parce
que est-ce qu'elle me dit ce qu'elle
aime en tout cas dans cette école c'est
la reconnaissance des intelligences
multiples et l'égalité des talents
est-ce que c'est des retours qu'on vous
fait régulièrement au sein de votre
école tout à fait d'ailleurs on a même
des enfants qui se pensaient très mateux
et finalement ils sont très mateux et au
fait très artistique aussi donc on donne
la possibilité à chaque enfant de
d'explorer plein de choses différentes
et de construire et et de mettre en
pratique des choses
très théoriques à la base et voilà donc
il y a des révélations pour certains
enfants et justement cette école aussi
elle elle propose donc cette variété de
pédagogie est-ce qu'à votre avis il y
aurait aujourd'hui des solutions à
mettre en place dans les écoles
publiques parce qu'on sait que votre
école est assez onéreuse est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a des choses à faire en
tout cas dans le saignement public de
manière adaptée sans forcément dépenser
des sommes oui je pense que je pense que
chaque professeur est en capacité de
pouvoir incorporer de l'extérieur dans
son dans son quotidien alors peut-être
pas tous les jours mais par exemple je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'écoles donc
sous contrat d'État qui le mercredi le
mercredi sur deux pour faire des
activités à l'extérieur ou en forêt
c'est quelque chose qui se planifie qui
peut tout à fait s'organiser
après il faut avoir de l'intérêt pour la
chose et regarder en ligne tout est
accessible en ligne il y a plein d'idées
et voilà il faut juste y aller et avoir
l'idée de le faire je pense que c'est
possible d'ailleurs j'encourage tout le
monde à le faire plus d'être plus à
l'extérieur vous en c'est quoi de cette
école Joël gigouzeau
c'est clair c'est c'est une école privée
moi je suis plutôt pour l'école publique
même en intégrant une partie de ce que
ce qu'a dit
la référence mais je suis vraiment pour
que l'école publique joue totalement
sans rôle il fasse réussir les élèves
quoi voilà et là c'est bon dans ce cas
là c'est pas le cas d'inspiration pour
l'éducation nationale
pourquoi pas mais ça l'éducation
nationale pour moi c'est vraiment la
seule qui peut qui peut faire réussir
mais l'ensemble des élèves dans les
quartiers populaires comme dans les
quartiers riches tout à fait d'ailleurs
il faut savoir que ce type de
d'enseignement dans certains pays c'est
pas réservé aux écoles privées mais
c'est vraiment incorporé dans les écoles
publiques notamment en Angleterre donc
on n'a pas besoin de laisser ce petit
d'école à des privilégiés et je pense
que justement il faudrait s'inspirer
d'autres pays pour vraiment proposer
des activités alternatives et d'autres
pédagogies plus innovantes pour déjà
capturer l'intérêt des enfants parce que
chaque enfant a le droit et mérite
d'avoir une bonne scolarité une
éducation intéressante
est-ce que vous avez pour projet
d'ouvrir d'autres écoles en France pour
l'instant non
mais pas d'objectif dans ce sens des
écoles des écoles comme les miennes pour
l'instant non mais pourquoi pas enfin il
existe plusieurs écoles de type forest
cours en France mais elles sont souvent
réservées au mercredi ou samedi et déjà
notre modèle il est un peu hybride parce
qu'on a des classes et des salles de
classe donc les enfants passent de la
classe à l'extérieur mais la vraie
forest cours en Angleterre dans les pays
nordiques tout se passe à l'extérieur et
bien merci beaucoup
à nos questions donc je le rappelle vous
êtes la directrice de la forêt school
internationale school Régine raleche du
coup vous revenez la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique et du Talk
tout à fait je reviens pour parler d'une
association la courte échelle qui est
notamment les élèves à mieux s'insérer
dans la filière de la justice donc ce
sera la semaine prochaine on sera là
pour pour écouter tout ça ça a l'air
très intéressant